okay so um as you guys know I've talked
a lot about beautiful majestic creatures
on this channel for those of you that
know that no fat chicks now fat chicks
really get sensitive when we talk about
their weight and the truth is that men
prefer thinner healthy women and
typically what you see from bigger women
is that they get mad and they they just
[__] on me for this opinion but recently
an overweight woman has come out to give
her opinion on fat jokes let's pull it
up okay let's be real if you can't
handle the fat jokes who's the W okay
say BBL
sponsor oh wait actually I think that
was a dude I don't know I just I saw the
clip but seriously guys and I actually
love this because it's so much better
when you could just poke fun on yourself
I'm not saying to bully people into
Oblivion but I mean come on guys I'll
take a ginger joke you know what I mean
you can't get that big and not be able
to take a fat joke here or there and
we've sort of lost this ability in
America like like I remember when I was
a kid early 2000s I mean it was more
common to see racist sexist and
homophobic jokes like to say but as
women have entered the media and the
workforce you really see that going away
because and it's interesting that this
is a dude like actually that's saying
that because men are better able to take
being made fun of we're
women we just we just don't really do it
well and my plea to women is if you want
to be in a man's world if you want to be
on the internet if you want to be in the
media if you want to do all this stuff
then be in it be in it don't cry and
complain about being made fun of later
when you asked to be in a guy's world
that you didn't have to be in and that's
why you see this phenomenon when women
enter a space like politics media and
corporations you see this phenomenon of
people policing speech Human Resources
lawsuits Etc when at the end of the day
we cannot police speech we can't and
again I say if you want to be in a man's
world be in it